all right through through through dark
and through the dark times and a lot of
times I promise you that I will make
things brighter and higher for you and I
promised you I would be a perfect father
for you offer for our children for Isaac
I promise to be a perfect father and I
promise to love our children just as
equally no matter of blood or or through
love or blood and I promise to you that
I will be the perfect partner your best
friend and the simple things I feel like
are the hardest things to promise
simply just being side by side and being
happy I think oh those are hardest
things I promise I think simply being
happy laughing side by side presents I
forgot the last thing I promised to you
that uh that all those small moments the
most important moments the ones that are
overlooked those are all super
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
well I now pronounce you Casey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it crashed midway through but then their
moaning so they got to see you like
probably didn't see about that was a
wonderful time
happy birthday Merry Christmas and a
happy Halloween
[Music]
you have anything to say Aaron to the
wedding couples beach lifts you guys are
beautiful people I'm so happy to be here
[Music]
oh my gosh I like I could I cheered I
teared a little I'm like I can't handle
it I need to keep it together I don't
even know why I would be apologizing
because I'm just so happy for them well
let Julia be right now we'll come back
later it's the man of the hour I just
not now but you know I pulled things out
the sleep it was a magician he's a mutt
a magician we're gonna go hear some
music now guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well I'm just you want to help so do you
think it would be good to have yeah yeah
I think it crash midway through yeah
yeah it crashed midway through sorry
guys the crash would way through but
then you know we got it back on as fast
as we could yeah hi Jessica though we're
back on yeah we've been on
[Music]
sneer with aks filmin Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]